he just took off and ran
I know he's scared over and breaks my
heart
let's go find him
[Music]
this time on trackers so a house cat
bolts our front door was wide open come
on let's find that cat the heat is
overwhelming the terrain on trusty is
substantial and it's really skittish
desperation sets in he really only likes
cheese
foreign
[Music]
trustee the veteran Bloodhound might not
be a morning dog I haven't got your bag
once she's off the couch and on her way
to track she's in her element a job she
was born and trained to do good with 150
successful rescues with her partner
Wendy trustee has the resume to prove it
I love what I do I love being a Tracker
but more than anything I love trusty
today they'll work together to try and
bring Ripken home
I've had him since he was about eight
weeks old
[Music]
a little tiny guy
he's just a little 12 pound Cockapoo
which is a little sweetheart
I came outside and I noticed the gate
was open
ripken's not here and we frantically
started searching the neighborhood
[Music]
I couldn't find him I couldn't find him
anywhere
rip I know he's really really scared out
there and
breaks my heart
is out there
it's by himself he's just a lovely guy
but I want to find a
Ripken was last spotted at a sprawling
construction site two miles from his
home
the search begins here wow this is way
back I had no idea it went back this far
we'll carry the center article
just lay it down
a scent article ripken's favorite
blanket has his DNA all over it
come on come on
Bloodhounds were bred to detect and
analyze scent particles trustee's
oversized ears sweep odors into her nose
she's honed in on an invisible trail of
microscopic skin cells left behind by
Ripken with him being so little he can
find Refuge
areas
groundhogs and raccoons
see those spots where it goes in between
it's like where something is walked
through recently
they are definitely canine tracks
trustee this is a muck
mud
which way you want to go Trust
okay
she's definitely found his water source
indications are that he had come down
for water and probably backtracked is an
awesome thing because that's one of
ripken's needs they can live without
food for like three weeks you need that
water you can only make it three days
[Music]
two miles into the track in 90 degree
heat trustee isn't showing any signs of
fatigue
going through the woods with the 110
pound dog on a leash that's 15 feet it's
it's crazy come on up here and we'll go
around come on
you gotta go around sticks you got to go
around rocks you got to climb over
folders
trustee Works an arduous track as hard
as when she was a young working dog
no need I'm falling down
the stuff and she's just fine
there's a huge huge nesting area that's
probably coyote
coyote populations have been on the rise
in Maryland since the 1970s and are a
predatory threat to a 12-pound dog like
Ripken there's a lot of treacherous
stuff out here
it really has me frightful it is just
such a massive amount of property to
trace this fast little dog before he
gets eaten by some other animal
I'm just not sure
what I'll find tomorrow if we don't find
them tonight
[Music]
three-year-old German Shepherd a breed
popular with law enforcement and illegal
drug interdiction
she is definitely making her presence
known and finding pets left and right
Gretel and her partner Janelle fishpaw
have solved over a hundred missing pet
cases we're doing really good as far as
a team goes we've got a good good track
record so far
Gretel and Janelle are headed to track a
beloved house cat lost in central
Maryland
Jonas is a white and black domestic
short hair
we've had him for about two years
he's on the smaller side he's fairly
petite he hangs out with his family all
the time he's always with us
when we got up yesterday morning our
front door was wide open
and then we noticed that Jonas was
missing
we have three kids
I love him very much
[Music]
so we're just hopeful that this will
work
if I can just have you guys stand the
driveway here
okay so I'm wearing a glove so that I
don't put my smell on the scent article
to locate Jonas's scent Trail his pillow
is placed by the door he escaped from
his last known location
when she approaches descent item she
knows this is the smell that I'm looking
for despite all the other scents here
the strongest one coming off this item
is what we're gonna find incredible suit
[Music]
when Janelle uses German commands Gretel
knows it's time to work
she's got the scent
incredible
gretel's nose is one hundred thousand
times more sensitive than a human's
suit
gretel's tracking technique looks more
like what you would expect to see out of
a dog that's tracking her nose is to the
ground some of the dogs such as hounds
they can track with their head up a
little higher she's nose to the ground
look missing cats typically stay within
a thousand feet of home with the summer
heat rising Jonas likely has taken cover
somewhere away from the Sun
we're cool into these window wells you
know behind bushes in odd locations
Gretel tracks Jonas's scent into a
neighbor's yard
soup
she had indicated that there was a lot
of strong smell on the back side of the
house this find it
this looks good
come on let's find that cat
tle suit
Gretel just sat down which is her
indicator for me
Gretel signaling that Jonas was recently
at this deck
okay I'm just gonna take a flashlight
and look with Gretel sure
she's gonna sniff I'm gonna use my eyes
and a flashlight we'll see if we can't
get any eye shine or she doesn't
indicate for us that there is a cat
under the deck I know where's the kitty
cats typically can weasel themselves
into small tight spaces
there's a good like eight to ten inch
Gap in there
I was able to look under the deck there
and he's not there
yes that's where you smell the cat
there's so there's a lot of scent
under there
I was a pretty strong scent trail that
was kind of backing around
Jonas was here but likely left this
hiding spot in search of food and water
pop across the street
gretels lost the trail
when that happens Janelle's training
kicks in
she leads Gretel to ReDiscover Jonas's
track and search for where the
frightened cat might be hunkered down so
don't forget to check up as well as on
the ground because he'll definitely
scoot up a tree
all right girl where's the kitty
where's the kitty
a sand cat you do Joe
[Music]
hop across the street
Gretel lost the scent Trail for Jonas a
cat that went missing last night
we've had them for about two years
love him very much
Jonas is an indoor cat vulnerable to
countless threats don't forget to check
up as well as on the ground
let's find that cat come on let's find
her Janelle has greatly expanded the
search range going right to the edge of
the nearby wood line oh oh I stand hat
Joe
all right girl we want to really
pinpoint where the cat's at if we flush
the cat out the cat's gonna run and move
locations
gretel's Behavior indicates that
whatever cat Dawn saw it's not Jonas
there are no signs of Jonas having been
here
I mean I wouldn't be surprised if
there's multiple cats in here
even though they're running out of
daylight Janelle has another section of
the neighborhood to canvas
I just want to be thorough and sweep
through the area just to make sure
[Music]
and it works Gretel is once again locked
onto Jonas's Trail
and it leads into a neighbor's yard
[Music]
[Music]
oh oh I heard him I heard him you heard
him he's in here
Joe
do you see him oh God okay I gotta stay
calm he's getting scared
hi buddy mommy's right here
come here baby
come on honey
did you see him yeah
hi
okay
do you have them have them no not yet
okay
hi
okay yay hi
[Music]
thank you guys
when you see an owner be able to pull
their lost cat out of the Bush it's just
it's such an amazing feeling I know
Gretel was hitting on that bush so the
fact that she's right and the cat's
there and the owner's excited is just
it's it's awesome I am so glad Jonas is
home
make sure that front door gets closed I
just don't want to get out again
what are you doing
it's on an adventure
um
Gretel thank you so much
we helped us find Jonas didn't you thank
you
[Music]
ah she wants to go in these people's
backyard
Ripken a five-year-old Cockapoo ran away
four days ago he's not a very good
street smart dog he's a very docile dog
he's a very friendly dog
[Music]
I know he's really really scared out
there and
breaks my heart
trustee tracked him to a neighborhood
three miles from home
significant activity on the edges of
these houses here believe me to believe
that the dog has been in here
there's every chance Ripken is nearby
Scavenging for food I am not relieved
that trustee led me to a neighborhood
I'd rather him stay away from the roads
at this point we're all tired the dog is
even tired searching for Ripken since
Wendy suspects Ripken is in this area
it's time to shift from tracking to
trapping from this point forward it's
going to be strategic planning I would
like to put a trap between the field and
the house
her plan is for a single trap
she wants to put down one trap
it's like one trap 270 some Acres
despite Colin's concerns Wendy is
confident she's using her resources
efficiently
this is what they call a trail camera
the camera covers a radius of 80 feet
triggered to record at the slightest
motion if Ripken goes for the bait he'll
be caught on camera confirming Wendy's
theory that Ripken is here
there you go
it will be up to Colin and Jamie to
Monitor and rebate the Trap
I'm not very confident in the plan
but I do know that without somebody
having a plan I don't have one Wendy
does
there's no way in hell with all this
acreage and this terrain that we're
gonna find them tonight I just hope he
makes it through the night
before he became a world-class tracking
dog Jake was caged up in a kill shelter
this High Strung coonhound has gone from
someone's cast off to a top-notch
Tracker today Jake is working with
Carmen Brothers to find a Doberman
Pinscher named Simba unfortunately since
Simba has only been in this home for a
short time he's also not very familiar
with the area so it's going to be more
challenging for him to find his way home
Simba is a year and a half old
he's like he has really bad anxiety he's
really skittish
let me get like really attached and vote
to me
then he follows me everywhere at the
house
I'm so scared
[Music]
it's been 24 hours since Simba got loose
while on a run with Cecilia's stepdad
John
about halfway through we saw a deer and
he just took off and ran I think we need
to get it done quickly he'd get hit by a
car that's what I'm doing
where'd you drop the leash exactly
pretty much right here okay
foreign
about the only time Jake is calm is when
he is centing up
what normally happens when dogs go
missing like this especially when
they're already really skittish they
tend to hunker down and they tend to
really not come out except for like
between Dusk and Dawn because that's
when there's less noise and less
activity and so forth
and kind of see he's trying to pick up
the scent now with his nose up in the
air
this way Jake was falling like exactly
where my stepdad said that he had seen
Simba running he's accurate
Simba is easily being taken for a deer
a lot of times people will you know see
him and not even realize it's Simba
because he just Blends in so well with
the surroundings
Jake so you see how he's kind of
freaking out that's what he does
normally when the scent gets stronger
Simba has definitely been here very
recently
get down get down
hi
do you want to go to the dog park
just saw Simba literally right here
right now
I gotta get Jake in the park I don't
want him to freak your dog out
Jake's amped up and that could actually
scare Simba provoking him to flee the
woods and onto the highway Carmen's
strategy pivots the family needs to draw
Simba in what I want you to do we're
going to kind of split we're gonna go in
from either side get your scent items
and drop your scent strips as you walk
back that way okay
these pieces of blanket are covered in
Cecilia 's scent the goal is to make
Simba feel comforted by The Familiar
smells
the first of two efforts to lure him to
her have a seat somewhere you're comfy
I'm going to surround you with cat food
The Dog's right here somewhere I've got
Celia who he's most familiar with
sitting down in the woods with cat food
and whatnot in silence in hopes of being
able to lure Simba to her
cat food is a pungent powerful draw to
an animal that may not have eaten in
days
don't move
pretty much because if we keep walking
around we're gonna end up pushing the
dog out
I would keep them coming this way
towards you
super simple
[Music]
Jake tracked down a runaway Doberman
named Simba around other people he's
really skittish but he really only likes
me
Simba is on edge suffering severe
anxiety let's eat some more the focus
turns from tracking him to catching him
I went to see you literally to sit down
and be in total silence we're looking to
take wet cat food and kind of circle it
around her so hopefully that attracts
Simba to come closer to her
where she doesn't have to go to him to
get a hold of the leash or get a hold of
him
pretty much
Simba do you want to go to the dog park
hi
hi sweetie
we're okay we're okay okay wait wait
wait wait wait
[Music]
when we're tracking and people see their
dog you know they obviously expect their
dog to recognize them and come up to
them but unfortunately that's not the
way it works
yeah right there
Simba is in flight mode which is when a
dog gets out they almost revert back to
being feral they don't associate that
relationship they turn around and run
given how panicky he is any bid to draw
him towards Cecilia will likely fail
people travel through the woods all that
does is scare him he'll start
associating this area with fear and in
turn he'll move and not come back to
this area
the best option at this point set a trap
and get out of the woods just dump all
that kind of yep
we're gonna want to take the sheets and
stuff that you guys ripped up and
literally we're gonna do scent Trails
leading in so yep let's shred away
this looks awesome by the way this is
great we have the scent Trails leading
into the Trap we'll just keep Paws
crossed and
wait for Tim to come to us
I don't want a great big search party
coming in and freaking Simba out but if
one person comes in every once in a
while and just sits quietly that could
actually help lure him in
Jake took our area from being the entire
woods and the surrounding area to this
smaller portion of the woods nice thank
you thank you
oh yeah
Jake continues to hold on to Simba's
scent even as they drive away
Jake has one switch as we can all hear
it's either on or off
he's definitely on right now and
probably more frustrated than I am
because he's
he's ready to roll and it just doesn't
always take place that day
right Jake
[Music]
we're gonna get a trap
and we're gonna set him back here
ripken's been gone from home for almost
an entire week
they always stuck by my side
never did he leave me
and I know he's scared
trustee pinpointed an area where Ripken
has been hanging out near what could be
a Coyote Den
Colin and Jamie have visited daily to
check on the Trap and motion camera I'm
just gonna keep doing everything you
tell me to do and don't give up don't
give up never gonna give up you can't
give up so
[Music]
six days and no sign of Ripken
until now
Ripken could not resist the bait
a trap secures the dog
[Music]
and during Jamie's daily routine
hi baby well it was very early in the
morning
I got to that trap Wendy itself
he was in it stay with me
stay with me I carried the whole entire
crate
to my car
I wasn't going to open it because I
didn't want to lose them
I just got a phone call a little while
I'll see Jamie over her house they got
their dog Ripken
[Music]
there he is
a little scared and he's a little
skinnish tonight that's going to be that
way for a little bit but because of you
got a bit
you are beautiful oh yes you are
without her I couldn't have brought him
home
that makes me proud of my dog it makes
me proud of your dog and it makes me
proud of you
never thought this would happen
this time I've pretty much seen the
headlights of the Lord's catalog
I couldn't believe it
Gretel is up early hey now hello hi
Greta anxious to start the work day with
her Handler Janelle yeah you gotta and
wills owns Gretel and other tracking
canines she trained this Duo Gretel
with over 2 000 pet recoveries Anne's
the mother of trackers work her hard
bring her back tired I always do let's
go hold on incredible track with anybody
no
no she's a super super social dog
and as long as somebody's holding that
leash
off she's ready to go
the first time in her career Gretel has
been assigned to track a ferret
my pet's name is Thorne he's a ferret
he's he's my little fur baby I love him
he's
I had
[Music]
Thorn squeezed out of a hole in a screen
door and has been gone for a week much
longer and the odds are stacked against
a recovery
we're moving next two weeks or so it
really worries me is not being able to
find him
he was a real big part of our family
oh my God that's gonna be awesome
we're using Thorn's bed as a scent
article perfect
girl
that are unique to doing a ferret track
you're looking in even smaller locations
than you would for a cat or a small dog
they love those tight little spaces
ferrets are extremely susceptible to
heat stroke temperatures over 90 degrees
are considered dangerous since recently
temperatures have been nearing triple
digits Gretel soup oh yeah I get all
that smell
Thorn is still alive she's on it he's
likely in a small shaded area nine shook
don't want to go down here
see my biggest fear is right these
railroad tracks
not far from home an active railroad
track a serious threat to Thorne
we're not getting a lot of scent there
seems to be Pockets ascent
Gretel is struggling to keep Thorne's
scent her first ferret track is growing
cold
we've done the back over here I I want
to see about this backyard here
shoot come on Gretel picks up a fresh
Trail definitely some interest coming
down that Hill pulling them right where
they don't want to go train tracks make
me nervous
I've never had her try to pull me into
bushes I actually think that's probably
where he's at
that is a hot spot
[Music]
Gretel and her Handler Janelle are
trying to sniff out the new den of a
runaway ferret named Thorne who really
worries me is not being able to find him
he was a real big part of our our family
Thorn's been missing nearly a week at
the end of the month his family is
moving so the rescue window is closing
shook
there was definitely some interest
coming down that Hill
determined to find her
fur drettles aggressively signaling that
Thorne is close
I've never had her try to pull me into
bushes
she's traced Thorn to the brush
alongside an active railroad track
that is a hot spot I actually think
that's probably where he's at so I don't
want to Spook him out that's why we're
pulling back yeah right next to the
train tracks I really really am scared
for his safety here
we're baiting up this area because this
is my best bet on where Thorn's hiding
out to contain Thorne and keep him away
from the tracks They surround His
suspected hideout with food and traps
all right so then we'll go to the other
side here and we'll set up a feeding
station
the way feeding stations work you want
it big enough so you get at least one
set of footprints we put that there
and then we're gonna grab the flour we
want it thick enough that if you lightly
touch you get a print
yeah
flour will help determine if Thorns
eating from the station and potentially
lead the way to his new nest
and for bait we're going to take that
open can of cat food and you just stick
it right in the middle so he's got to
step onto it
on there to get it exactly exactly
that's what we're going for so we'll run
the chum Trail up and down the tracks
here
and maybe a couple of his favorite
treats
Chum is a mixture of water and cat food
it might deter him from crossing the
tracks in search of food
[Music]
as much as I'd love to be able to hand
you your pet I don't want to spook them
out and pour some well I understand that
[Music]
it's six o'clock in the morning the
forecast is calling for a scorcher
all right pop it in
it is so hot that you can hardly even
move
hang on girl she's a princess
yeah
to beat the midday Sun Wendy heads out
early to search for a little lost Yorkie
DD
just my son and I and it's his dog we've
had her for seven years
she goes up and down this fence line
looking for rabbits groundhogs because
she's a terrier that's what they're born
to do is dig and search things out you
can see all the two by fours that I've
put to try to keep her in the yard
I think that she got out underneath the
fence and somebody cornered her and
physically picked her up and took her
I'm not trying to be over dramatic but
my heart aches we miss our dog purebred
Yorkies can sell for over one thousand
dollars
easy they can be attempting Target for
thieves
stolen dog cases don't usually turn out
well I would say probably about 75
percent of them don't make it back if
you can just put that right there come
back behind me she likes to be the
leader of the pack
there you go
[Music]
find him
find it
that's what she went through right along
the side along this Edge
trusty finds one spot where there's a
hole underneath the fence and that's
where DD snuck out
what she's doing she's air centering
figure out which way
all right sit up with me
by air scenting trustee takes a shortcut
a direct path to the source of the scent
trustee showed me Interest into the area
around the storm drain
Dede was probably down here running
around and it shows me that DD's really
confused and she's trying to find a
place to hide and she's run everywhere
as we're going along I want you to keep
your eyes peeled any kind of movement
whatsoever okay
the day marches on the extreme heat
continues to rise with stifling humidity
dehydration is a lethal threat for The
Trackers
all right where does she turn around at
huh the physical
drain on trusty during heat like this is
substantial
she cannot track like she normally does
I'm trying to hold up but it's very hot
that's all I have to say it's a very hot
day today
we're gonna walk up here a little ways
I'm casting her around so I'm coming
back at you
casting is a technique to refocus
trustee on the scent path
it's not working
we've never walked down this way before
for her to come all this way on her own
it would be a shot trustee's energy is
flagging she's struggling to stay
adequately hydrated it's critical she
rests and cool off I had to physically
set her down down come on down
heat like this could destroy the whole
entire track
Dawn enlisted trusty to find her son's
lost Yorkie when I told him that you
know DD's missing he asked me Point
Blank he said so what are you doing
about it you know so this is what I'm
doing about it
track progressed over a mile from Dawn's
but the sweltering heat knocked out
trustee
damn come on down I had to physically
set her down kind of just take a break
I'm starting to break down this is just
unbearable
trustee's well-being is Paramount Wendy
shuts it down it makes me sad to think
that we're gonna stop now
and potentially we won't be finding my
dog while trustee cools down in the car
Wendy and Dawn get started on the
recovery plan we're going to take this
cat food and we're going to put it in
this water they employ the standard
method a trail of scent strips and cat
food to lure DD home the issue on this
track it's a couple of miles and we're
going to squirt some of the cat stuff I
feel hopeful we could find her if you go
up another 20 feet or so
I do have some doubts I am a little
skeptical
and articles are in place but Wendy
can't stay to reassure Dawn
her Focus turns to taking care of
trustee
it's just so hot I've got to get trusty
home get her cooled off
she's exhausted you know and I have to
be the one that realizes she's exhausted
and take care of her she can't tell me
she's tired so that's the game plan get
home cool down get some rest so we can
go back out tomorrow
it's been two days since Jake LED
Cecilia to Simba
her Panic Doberman
he was in full flight mode but good news
infrared footage confirmed Simba didn't
run far it also provides valuable Intel
every morning Simba visits the area but
completely avoids the Trap
it's early morning Cecilia is at work
her mom is waiting alone hoping to
recover Simba
I cat food literally in my hand and sat
by myself
and I saw him
[Music]
he was walking in front of the traps
and he walked over to me
eventually he started to get closer and
then just reached down and grab the
swish
[Music]
she called me and she was crying and
she's like I haven't and I was crying
and I was like okay I'm coming I'm
coming
it was very emotional
I was just glad that he was home
today he just slept all day
[Music]
ready handsome
the advice that Carmen gave this way
just going back and baiting the traps
was what helped me find my dog
very happy that he's home
[Music]
heat can be hard on all animals
Wendy isn't taking any chances with
trustee's health during this heat wave I
brought her home and gave her a bath I
tried to cool her off
to get her settled down she slept for
like the next two days because she was
so tired trusty is out of commission and
back on the couch until the weather
breaks even with a major development in
the case of DeDe the Lost Yorkie
and wills picks up where the case left
off
the owner is not home so I am going to
zip over there and see what I can find
[Applause]
[Music]
Deedee is here I see her reality is when
you're finding a missing pet you've got
a moving Target
and that pet is going to move
way before you even get near it because
animals have a better sense of hearing
and smell than we do it takes a split
second for a dog to get away from you
and it's in flight mode
and she's very cautious I got to be
really careful that I don't run her off
Didi
this is the first time Dede the Yorkie
has been seen in five days I've been
sick about it to be honest never in our
seven years of having her has she ever
been gone
but she's creeping from yard yard to
yard
and she's very cautious
so I got to be really careful that I
don't run her off
the scent trails that were laid earlier
lured her home
Katie come here baby
[Music]
with strangers Yorkies are aloof by
nature and tend to be wary
there's a whole art form to catching a
dog by hand to doing pretty girl
during her years of experience and has
learned how to make herself
non-threatening to Yorkies
what you need to do right now
try and get as close as I can to or
without spooking her and then I gotta
drop to the ground I'm not going to give
her any direct eye contact at all
because that is a challenge to a dog so
you're I'm not going to look at her but
I'm going to get down really low and I'm
actually going to try and crawl over to
her he's so skinny
gotta get her attention
[Music]
I'm gonna pretend like I'm crying
[Music]
deedy believe that I'm hurt and they
need help
you hungry
go on
even though DD's a little dog I gotta
grab her tight and keep her from
squirming yummy cat food
and she will get away
foreign
[Music]
if we hadn't caught this little dog
today I don't think it would have made
it very much longer
it was extremely skinny extremely
dehydrated this dog is really thirsty
we have got to get her some food right
away
DD is physically distraught and must
take care of her until dawn gets home
Gretel and Janelle identified a
potential Hideout for Thorne the ferret
[Music]
dangerously close to a busy railroad
track I really really am scared for his
safety here
last night James went out to check the
Trap and look for Thorne
the traps across the street and there's
a storm drain right in front of them
where the Trap is
[Music]
after calling him a couple times I
looked right over and he was right here
through right here
all I could do is reach over grab him
and B-Line it back to the house
there you go parrot ferret
he's my little fur baby I love him
if it weren't for Janelle and and Gretel
I wouldn't have been able to find that
ferret
[Music]
having survived a heat wave for five
days DD is home
look who we got
[Applause]
hey
it just filled my heart with joy it made
all the hot sweaty work today all
worthwhile I know you miss home she's a
mess I don't think someone took DD she
came home covered in clay so I think
that she was chasing a groundhog or some
sort of small rodent I love her often
okay
come on baby
oh my goodness
to see somebody reunited with their
little baby that's why we do this there
you go baby girl you're so skinny I
think she lost about two pounds and she
only weighs four pounds
oh look at that she was shaking she
seemed very much disoriented
um but it's a comfort to have Dede back
home look at her yeah she's trying to
jump up we love her and we missed her oh
and she's happy again and I'm gonna give
her a good bath and yeah give her a good
meal and give her some good loving
and make an action plan yeah so know how
not to lose her well and now you know if
she does get away you know what to do
right thank you
thank you I appreciate it bye bye
sweetheart
bye-bye couldn't ask for a better finale
a little dog is home safe and sound
[Laughter]
I'm so happy she's home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]